no I'm saying I don't know meter gotten
did that or caught my family like so let
me come home I'm gonna just change my
whole life so I'm like you know I'm back
to it you feel me because this game is
addicting all right Tasha yeah Tasha
where'd you grow up where you from I'm
from Compton California and tell me
about your family
well my family I grew up my mother she
was on drugs and my father was also on
drugs but we my grandmother raised me
along with my other siblings I know two
other siblings and I grew up in Compton
where I don't we grew up with my aunt
Edie my uncle's like all flows around
the same age and I just remembered like
you know that's been the cool family at
first none of me and things changed as I
got a little older what kinda stuff
changed my attitude the way I am the way
I became you know started gangbanging
first and I led to prostitution which
you know I mean it hasn't changed since
I started prostituting
no what age 16 I started Preston at age
16 and um my first encounter was I want
to be a person since I was a juvenile
hall I was a very bad kid and ain't
gonna juvenile hall when I was a
juvenile hall had a lot of time to do
and I end up meeting a lot of young
girls being prostitutes so I wanted to
try it because they made it look so fun
like a lot of girls 12 13 14 15 all the
way you know 17 you know they took the
body made thousands you know I'm saying
and when they when they get caught you
know they had paperwork you know they
have reports when they get caught up so
you reading a report here like oh this
[ __ ] 12 years old and she made a
thousand dollars off one night Oh
you know I'm with that so when I got out
I never I said I want to do it I said
I'll tell myself oh I'm gonna be ho I've
never I told myself that in juvenile
hall and I never thought it'd happen so
soon but two weeks after I was out of
Youth Authority exciting getting senses
use authorities I end up running into a
pen and when I went into a parent I'm
not gonna say the name but when I ran
into him he was so fine and so so
everything you had to say was so right
and so real because I was looking for
that love like I was in for my mother
and my father you know I'm saying and
everything you say let me take care of
you I'm gonna do this i'ma do that I'm
gonna make sure you write you know he
did that well no you know I'm saying
first guy when he did that for me he got
my hair done make me look like it you
know saying I don't never knew I had
what I had that much party I had and a
cute face you know I was just fresh out
of way you know sense still kind of like
boy it's still kind of like a tomboy so
when I met him he put me in a dress and
I started seeing almost attention I can
get in no my first night he asked me to
do it for him my first night I made $500
in one hour
so I'm like oh I'm pretty you know I'm
this I'm that and I never looked back
from there and I I have a lot of respect
in the streets like someone's respect
where I'm like a renegade you know what
I'm saying I don't have to have a pimp I
don't have to mm be scared on the
streets because I can pull up are you
straights price a lot of girls don't get
that a lot of girls get harassed me or
jump out and get beat up or you know
saying I'm saying that no guys ever
tried me and beat me Airport you know
I've gotten mark my probably like second
week in the game I got raped boy I guess
they call him the rapist that they
caught or whatever he's saying all the
girls down the Figueroa i I I think I
wanted a um I don't know some was one of
the first girls or like in my error to
get called by him but he never he hurt
my back and here my neck but he told me
if I do everything right he wasn't gonna
hurt me you know I'm saying and he took
my clothes my shoes
he took my dress my shoes keeping me in
a black t-shirt and drive me
Rosecrans in central I'll never forget
he raped me though I saw so I'm only 16
he didn't care he just digs if I ever
see you out there again I'm uh I'll get
you whatever the next day I'm not gonna
like the next day my own did my pimp
then care he still send me back out
there so the next day I see him he pull
up in his truck like this and I start
running and then I'm moving a Mexican
girl getting in the truck with him and I
remember her coming back cut up I've
been through so much on the streets of
prostitutes it's really crazy and I've
been pursuing since I was 16 I'm 34
right now and I've never experienced
doing crack I'll never experience
crystal no I never did cocaine what's up
ecstasy yeah I'm not gonna lie that's my
choice jerk it's ecstasy weed I smoked
that all day I don't care about but one
thing I've been strong in the streets
with I'm 34 years old how they younger
than half these girls I come and you
know do what they do but I've been
through a whole lot also and in this
game this game is very very very crazy
you know what I'm saying
and I've been successful like my brother
I brought my brother to the game you
know what I'm saying he end up getting
40 years for this is what a pen is a pen
mm-hmm my brother he was on a news in
from Compton when they say that he was
pipping young girls and all that and
then the guy turns out it was three of
them one of them our cousin and when I
was the guy turns out to the game you
know I mean he and up getting some time
to like I've been through a lot in this
game but it's I mean it's been fun I
can't Laura you got your fun gotta bend
through every state you can name you
know to me and get in money today
your pimp would travel with you yeah are
you going Your Honor I've been on my own
so so many times it's crazy because I
just a renegade thing a lot you know I
mean I don't because my trust issues are
very hard you know to me there's a lot
of girls I get off here cuz I've been
like recently I was in a relationship
where I was getting beaten hit and you
know so I'm not saying getting forced to
go out there cuz I was going out there
anyway but you know he don't know if you
want to meet a hoe
or if he wanted me to be a regular girl
you know what I mean and it just got
crazy from there you know to me and I
have to I've been run away from you know
I've been i wasn't for like a month you
know to me I had to get away because I'm
start seeing scratches on me and bruises
on me that I I should even have on me
you know me broken for you you know me
because he want to go you don't know if
you wanna do this baby mama me you know
to me he don't want me I don't know if
you want me to ho don't hope you know to
me but I'm strong out here so you know
me I've been shot and everything so are
you engaged I've been shot when I was
what 15 I got shot in the arm and the
leg you know I mean and I've missed
wrong yeah I'm just I just got my strong
individual you know me I feel like my
story should be heard because I've been
through a whole lot you know yeah it's a
lot of stuff that I haven't named out
that I've been through but you know know
me do you have kids of your own
I don't have any kids no kids I don't
have any kids because I don't wanna I
don't want to bring my no kids out here
in these streets and I watch these girls
struggle so hard you know I mean they
struggle hard you know I mean then it's
girls I hate I get that kids cooking
because they trying to survive out here
in the street they you know me where
they don't have no job after ok there
are here prostituting so now that you
know kid took him by DCFS because they
are here trying to make a living and
stuff not going right you know I mean I
watch all that should go down I didn't
you know me
I hadn't seen pimps drop the baby off if
the girl don't want to be with him they
didn't drop the baby off at the police
station it's just been it's a crazy
world on here that's why I don't have
any kids I don't want no right now never
was to settle down and I miss the right
guy and get married even though I was
late story
I would want to do it you know I mean
but I don't want to do my kid I here to
do what I'm doing right now no what
would you say to a young girl who's
considering doing something like that I
was maybe you know you don't need to
like it's a matter of fact it's a girl
that I've met recently and she's
probably six months pregnant
she's out here prostituting letting guys
have sex with her doctor yesterday great
here Ritter mm-hmm it's about it's a
love it you know and she doesn't respect
I told her having a baby is
is a very precious moment you don't want
your baby out here you letting guys run
through you like a train hey you know me
haven't said why you got your baby in
your stomach you're here prostituting
y'all here trying to fight you don't
need to do that but having a baby is a
very beautiful thing but it's a very
dangerous thing also because they can
also kill you if you have a miscarriage
it can also kill you you know what I
mean or you having a baby out here and
you doing what I'm doing in the game or
you have a pimp and a pimp mad because
it's not a baby they might do something
you never know where are you bringing a
baby to you know what I mean
you never know hard guy my field it's
not my baby oh my you know me i'ma hurt
this or this [ __ ] did something wrong
now I'm gonna [ __ ] this baby up or you
know me I'm gonna [ __ ] this [ __ ] up and
take her baby you never know have
another [ __ ] raise the baby it's just
it's a lot of [ __ ] I've seen out here
that's crazy so that's why we're not
have no kids I'm here and I would tell
the young girl you out here don't get
pregnant use protection baby because if
it was just the same do you get
depressed sometimes a lot I like it
sometimes it'd be like a struggle to be
out here doing what I'm doing especially
with no stability like I don't have
stability right now I don't have a
partner metal you know me like I was
just um I was just sleeping I don't know
the girl that you interview before yeah
I was just even at the house you know to
me and they have fleet galore you know
side to back up and like you know what
I'm saying like it's not me I need
somewhere to go but Fergie don't just
like to start back doing what I'm doing
you know what I mean but I end up
meeting a nice guy and I haven't
prostituted or any of that you know me
he pressuring me for sex or nothing he
liked me for me but it's like I don't
trust it I have very high trust that you
saw I'm not even giving him a chance you
know of me and you know he ain't asked
me are you going outside or all the
girls up in a motel room is holding and
doing all that he hasn't did he grab me
Mommy did everything for me I don't have
any girls right now he did everything
for me but it's like I don't trust them
cuz I'm like what is your motive you
know what I mean like how much money do
you make it a night depends on what
night it is like if it's like a I'm
saying like a Monday through
Wednesday a party make like I like for
400 or so month if it's like a Thursday
through like Sunday thing I probably
make like toaster like 900 it depends it
just depends some things would be slow
for me though I mean since all this
stuff is going on I've been like really
slow so she like to say like I haven't
been I'm sorry lady but what I was going
outside I don't make like 175 Reis like
lady no you know I mean and that's if
that do you remember your first time
come on my first time my first time was
what it might turn out um folks which
first time the first time you press to
do yeah
okay um my channel for he set up a date
for me before I even went out he said a
date up for me so I can feel comfortable
because I wasn't having sex all this
[ __ ] happening all I should have enough
to be going getting out of jail and so
your first time having sex was working
as a prostitute um no yeah I went him
first and then you know to me he got me
comfortable with someone of that you
know a trick yeah you know me and I
trick gave me um what 300 in my hand to
make me feel comfortable you know and it
was like he told me everything to do
always never put a price in your life
that's my turn now folks that's why I
always respect him he always told me I
don't care how much they got never do it
to John but on condom never because if
they're paintings they're trying to pay
you that you wanna pay you to give you
something your honor me cuz they don't
know if you clean or not they don't know
how many times you do this thing on me
how many times you know me how many guy
who said yes to put all the condoms you
know I mean so if they try to do it see
Florida condom
never put a price in your life yes
that's I know I always stuck with that
that's all you know me I'm safe near him
know I could take an HIV AIDS test and
not worry about oh I'm scared because I
know I've been out here having
unprotected sex you know
a lot of girls out here doing it for for
funds for money but I mean you can get
the same amount of money with using
protection because I have you know to me
even with conversations like even where
conversations always been lucky like to
get get good money you know to me cuz
good company is good money you know I
mean it ain't always about sex some
people be lonely and they've run a
little company you know I mean and
they'll pay for that and if anything
happens actually you know is that it
happens but are you being loved before
yeah have you been in love before you
have been in love before and I got hurt
you know ii mean so now I'm scared I'm
scared to love you know what I mean
because sometimes we think is love is
really not love it's you can it's what
you can do for it like in this game is
what you can do for a guy cuz you could
easily lose his attention in his love
for the next girl if she can give him
more you know what I mean so you think
your loving oh I'm in love with this guy
and he would say oh I love you you know
me and that's just something that these
pimps say to girls
they might not love you but they know
what you can do for them more you know
to me it must be hard to have a real
committed relationship with with the
career this like this yeah I'd be
feeling like like I'll never find nobody
that's gonna learn me for me because of
my lifestyle I feel like that like even
I could be the prettiest girl read we
you know me I could be the prettiest
girl in like my lifestyle determines
everything you know what I mean my
lifestyle determines everything I can I
can be dressed the best pretties that's
the best personality book because I
prostitute I will never find a buddies
like you know I mean that's gonna let me
for me like you know me a guy even if it
is a guard I do I don't trust it it's
like my trust issues are at all-time
high you know to me it's like I'm gonna
buy you a chance Ark I want to maybe
like to him believe them but it was like
my caution button go up and it's like no
you don't love me you love what you
heard about what I can do or you know
what I mean
as a guy right now like I only be
talking
I'm playing like a week - almost two
weeks and he said when he loved me but I
don't believe him you know what I mean
cuz you don't nobody love you know me
you're doing for me yeah
but before you got a motive probably not
Carly so none of me I don't know - how
long we ever how long we spent you know
I mean if he doesn't if you get to know
me right or if you'd be like oh she
don't want to have sex with me so could
we have a sec [ __ ] so it's like she
don't want to do nothing with me and
I've spent all this money
oh I'm cool on that I show that's no
love you know I mean so I don't know
I'll be something like I'll never find
nobody cuz my lifestyle how do you think
this life has changed you it changed me
tremendously because not only in my
books when I'm free smart you know to me
and um
I'm a lot cautious and I go off my first
mind and and all money all money ain't
good money to me if I felt because I had
a friend me hurry to be in competition a
whole lot we subpoena we used to be on
faith we should be in 84 feet we've been
competition a whole lot she's gonna date
I'll go on a date with you know saying
we'll do a date together and and one day
we did a together and then the guy was a
felon her so he told her she can he gave
her some money Tony she can she can
leave when we hurt medium kick the front
of the wall when I come back outside
she's still outside so when I come back
outside we're talking and stuff like
that his car pulled up so when the coral
is a everybody interviewed in my
interview room she's laughs there's an
interview and we like um we got a bad
vibe we got a bad vibe you know the man
halo-halo and she like oh yeah cuz rich
rest in peace where the type of girl she
like or money you know mean [ __ ] please
you know I'm saying he got the money I'm
going you know to me I don't give a [ __ ]
what y'all talking about so she like all
y'all missing money he's jumped in the
car ran never came back raid was found
they found red dead all the waiting what
is it Apple Valley and I would never
forget the car because it was a burgundy
car and uh when you get up on a car you
could save a guy you know
five a bottle and red is resting the
peace right now because you know me a
lot of girls be in competition this is
like a lot of stuff
tragically happen down here I got a
friend that I got a couple of girls that
I worked with that's resting in peace
you know I'm saying because we we want
to we want to find love we want to get
this money for our pimp like so bad I
all gonna make I'm gonna make more than
her so when he talks to my pimp he's
gonna know that I made more you know I'm
saying like and sometimes we don't think
we don't even think that think about our
first vibe I always go off my vibe like
if I not vibing you I'm not gonna you
know to me
if I even have a cringe in my skin about
you and and I'm broke I'm stay broke you
know to me I'm not gonna go
I'm just not because I because I I
follow my first mine that night and read
I don't know she had a bad vibe or she
just went to get more money cuz I'll
stay with the enemy and now she's gone
you know me and she was a different set
a lot of people we've been in the game
for a minute you know what I'm saying
this game I haven't seen it change
tremendously like now
it was pimping and pandering anyone from
people an impediment to human
trafficking because a lot of girls let
me tell you a lot of girls they get
arrested right they're not there a lot
of girls want to be victims and they get
arrested right so instead of them
telling the truth and be like oh I
turned the guy out because a lot of
girls we leave placement we leave all
type of places and we like we find a
boyfriend be like oh I know how to get
some money and you think a guy gonna say
um oh no don't do that
people if I was like oh I can make 500
others right now baby let me show you
how you don't think he gonna be like and
then I'm gonna have another friend she
can go I can do it too you know what I'm
saying
and that's how it all start every pimps
are here that's orphan student people
don't want to hear any story because
it's like they're they're known as the
bad guys you know I mean like pimps are
known as the bad guys but you gotta live
it you got different pins you got
gorillas you got finesse which is
finesse gorillas are the ones that Oh
[ __ ] you got to get outside and get my
money [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] about go
to hell I'll go to jail [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ]
fifteen police outside [ __ ] work around
them you know what I'm saying that's the
gorilla that's what I was doing when I
first got in the game and I didn't know
you know me and I got he did this to me
and all that because I was so crazy
about him because he has a long hair in
the light skin he was just fine you know
I'm saying
and then you gotta finesse it I don't
mess with a finesse camp before where he
don't even he felt he gotta touch you if
he got a touch to heat you can go you
know what I'm saying he's like I got so
many [ __ ] on me [ __ ] I got so many
[ __ ] pammi [ __ ] I don't even give a
[ __ ] about none of that said you talk
about you can go you know what I'm
saying
did you got the ones that's like
boyfriend and girlfriend pimps you know
I'm saying he only won one [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying he only won one
girl and y'all just getting our money
together like that you got so much so
many different type of people out here
that when they hear pimp they be like oh
that mother [ __ ] me that [ __ ]
not cool you know I'm saying because pin
know there's a lot of people that's in
jail right now that girls light on
because you got a good you got sale as
firing that's right we all in
competition because it's fine with us
and we got that one dude and everybody's
craving for attention he like it's about
one girl he like this about leather girl
he like you know saying it's and we
allow him to Pipo I was like oh we ain't
competition with each other so you
you'll have he really like one though
you know I'm saying it always be like
that you'll read like one so that's his
bottom [ __ ] you know I'm saying bottom
[ __ ] always really a girlfriend
you know I'm saying so you you'll have
one that's like a bottom [ __ ] you know
I'm saying and then we in competition
work so now he like oh this is my [ __ ]
so now another girl gonna be like oh I'm
telling on him I'm telling the police so
if buddy's be like Oh tell us your pimp
name and all that she already mad at him
so she's like [ __ ] that you know I'm
saying he ain't for strong sign and then
you know you notice a lot of girls with
guys names Terrell you know saying I
know you see a lot of girls with guys
names tatted on them and then they'll be
like oh oh he forced me to do this but
it works so neat people know it's a lot
of human trafficking out here that
that's not even um that's not even
knowing like you have a different race
human trafficking they already but you
they they so in two or a game right now
the pimp in the whole game and they
think everybody they want to change the
human trafficking or slavery or all that
we can get away if we want to you know
I'm saying we can write the girls choose
up to different pimps I wanna go with
him I'm gonna go with him I'm gonna go
in so that was the case why a lot of
girls not dead right now
you know what I mean it's just like a
funny game to me because this is
something that that they want to believe
like not saying that pimping cuz I don't
believe I'm not gonna I believe every
girl should get their own money
you're like because our masters the game
I know ain't nobody gonna tell me oh no
you can't go get your nails did that's
rising gave him five hundred dollars you
know I'm saying or no [ __ ] drinking our
feet today
tomorrow oh no you know saying when you
can go and make your own money cuz I out
right now and then go along but be FPS
and that's the boyfriend pants you know
saying and some guys I still think they
can have a lot of girls but everybody
run in a mug because the game is so
different than us human trafficking
people who are scared you know what I
mean
and but that is for me to say like a lot
of guys be orphans too you know so you
think they a lot of guys do you um home
this too
you think if a girl pretty ass girl
welcomes you like oh I don't know I I
could make us some money
how you like if it was you what would
you do like if a girl of you were
homeless and a girl like I know I could
make us some money
you're gonna tell her no don't do that
and she's still gonna do it you know me
with you or somebody else this game is a
dog-eat-dog world
and if I could some girls like [ __ ]
better him than me you know me but
they'll know that this guy facing the
rest of his life and you're not facing
the UM I'm facing six months for a
prostitute and they facing the rest of
their life because they they they got so
many trumped-up charges and ain't
getting [ __ ] but be nice to the girl the
whole time so what you're saying
rather than blaming the pin for the
entire situation sometimes it's the
female can we not we not take zero it
takes it takes two to tango and we knock
out the girls like oh come on sir my
[ __ ] oh you know so that's our job
that's that's the job that's especially
when you a bottom [ __ ] I've seen I've
been photographing and you're viewing a
lot of pimps and
- that I've seen the interactions
outside on the street a girl will sit
here with me saying all this negative
stuff about pimps I don't need that [ __ ]
I'm not gonna give somebody my money and
as soon as she steps outside and sees
that well-dressed cool dude she gets
weak in the knees and she's not standing
really close to him and look at him
looking up at him and well say you got
me I'm over them everybody know me I'm
ready
they call me renegade spice you know
what I'm saying I've been around for a
cool minute you know I'm saying I don't
have my shares of pimps when I was
younger you know to me and I'm very high
trusted you don't go [ __ ] up
[ __ ] put up in this
[ __ ] three million dollar suit
[ __ ] shrinking me I don't give a [ __ ]
because you for the game you know me
I didn't be through it been there done
it you know me never got me a guy and we
do it together
I didn't do that a couple of times you
know to me and you never know if they
want me to be a hoe or they want me to
be their girlfriend you know so they get
jealous that time because they don't
understand my lifestyle so like I said
that's why I feel like I'll never really
find love because soon as I get broke
off you like [ __ ] I need some fast cash
you feel me [ __ ] what he talking about
he ain't got no money for me you feel me
and just like on owe to this game you
know me sometime be like oh I want to
find love but then I'm lazy and love
[ __ ] I never understand me and they
won't you know I'm saying because you
got a family member it's very judgmental
you got people that's just seeing you on
Long Beach Boulevard on Figueroa you
know me I know you were home they people
don't want to bring that [ __ ] today
families you know what I'm saying
because they feel like you know me like
my family they don't redo none took
nothing for me you know I mean because I
their life I chose to live I wasn't
raised like this oh yeah we're gonna all
be hoes I wasn't raised like that no I
was raised in church and everything else
so I know my real mother turned it over
her gravesite watching me do this you
know me but it's something it's fast
cash I don't know if I could ever get a
job and be like you don't know saying my
story is a tragic story you know I'm
saying but people can't make it like the
game bent all bad because it has good
- you know me I don't have fun times not
I had bad times and that's what any life
story you know what I'm saying
like but what I wish is on anybody know
cuz it's um it's addicting you know I
mean you get out the game for a minute
like [ __ ] I ain't doing that [ __ ] no
more
I don't know how many times I've been to
jail right whoever changed my life
let's put it God God listen to me please
like if you let me out today I promise
you I ain't gonna do this no more so I'm
gonna get out on back to the game you
feel me forgot to say that you know me
so and a lot of us do that you know
don't say I don't know me talk about
indeed that or call my family like got
let me come home I'm gonna just change
my whole life so I get home I'm back to
it you feel me because this game is
addicting you know me I'd like a smoke a
lot of we got smoke push you feel me so
that being said like mushy I got it and
I don't like to just buy no $10 bag or
know that [ __ ] so I'll be willing to
spend my whatever I want to spend on I
got to the point where I spoil myself so
if I make someone ever gonna spend my
own money like everyone to buy this buy
that buy this buy that not enough for
like what a job you have to wait you
know I can't wait for no change I'll be
alright fast cash and that's just with
any girl I spin it in my lifestyle it's
hard for them to adjust to - um - trying
to have a job everybody oh you can give
a job I can but we're like no you know
it's staying like you know I mean I can
probably you know saying but it's hard
like especially every day you having
like a lot of money on hand like for one
night you know me you get like seven
honey
hey honey like [ __ ] all that I can wait
for no check
sorry are you saving money yeah are you
saving money I'm not gonna lie every day
is it because you it be some days I
don't go outside because I made seven
hundred so I'm like ain't gonna exams
gonna pay my rent like this I'm favorite
days I'm favorite taste you feel me when
we have week for like two days
no saying Nora I don't save money you
know I'm saying
and I'm not gonna lie like every day is
a struggle because I don't know if I'm a
hassle money or not because I want to
buy these I want to buy clothes I want
to buy this you know I'm saying and then
I ain't been working you know saying cuz
I caught a couple of cases also recently
so I ain't been working but it's a
constant struggle for me everyday and I
do by ourselves like I'm by ourselves
like oh here cuz my family there's
nobody messing with me right now because
the choices I made you know says it's
not their fault is my fault you know me
so your family knows they don't like it
so no nature they tried to help me when
they can't so I don't reach out either
because I'll be like come on here mama
I'm all your joining myself like because
it's always they have something to say
no sin instead of trying to help me they
always have everybody always have an
opinion
my mother's passed away so I have a
mother anymore and my father he doesn't
really do too much for me but it's the
choices I made you know my me already
Tasha thank you so much for sharing your
story
thank you
you